[Musique]
il a il a la pression parce que si saab
à courre est et à leur faisant faire
mieux que lui donc c'est un enfant qui
va voir son père et qui lui demande
papa c'est quoi la différence entre le
réel et le virtuel unibar avoir ta mère
est à seurre et demande leur si elles
sont prêtes à coucher avec un inconnu
pour un million d'euros
donc le l'enfant il va ya voir sa mère
sa soeur et revient il tient son père
m'a écouté l on dit que pour 1 million
d'euros bas après l'effort de couchey
qu'un inconnu lui ben écoute bas
virtuellement on est millionnaire est
réellement on a deux buts à la maison ou
au délà eric bas c'est un peu plus
poétique mais on démarre c'est pas si
facile tu deviens qui discute sont
radiés puis notre réussite et d'être
brigitte bardot mais le bébé ça y est on
lui ressemble
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un prêtre il est dans un petit
village qui cherche la poste gaffe
paixao ce qu'ils cherchent alors moi
c'est très tranquille a pas d'embrouillé
takpa et est donc là il chercha poste
mais à chaque fois qu'il parle à l'âme
excuser moi pas la poisse personnes le
calcul en la personne de calcul dans le
village mais y'a un mec il est bourré
était le prêtre est fait voir et tu veux
apporter ma poil à la poste serait
tournoi tu tourne à droite à gauche tu
te vole encore à gauche c'est la poste
le prêt qui fait ce que lui dit le mec
bourré oui trouve la poste il fait ses
affaires et quand il ressent ready le
seul mec qui m'a parlé c'est le mec
bourré je valais du prêcher la bonne
parole
il va vers le mail bout et il mêle
boyals prêtes tu à trouver la poste ne
doit j'ai trouvé et tu sais quoi tu es
tellement gentil que je voudrais te
montrer le chemin de dieu
le leap x 100 m
[Rires]
populaire
[Applaudissements]
j'ai fait de la prison
oui c'est se passe place vendôme à paris
place vendôme paris place vendôme les
bijoutiers tout ça ouais il ya un énorme
camion noir qui arrive il se gare devant
chez cartier le hayon des camions
sauf et il ya un éléphant énorme qui
descend à reculons comme ça la bonne
sortie fonce sur la vitrine de chez
cartier la défense et avec sa trompe et
puis tous les bijoux et en mon nom le
camion le héros se ferment et le camion
riba fort arrière voiliers de
gendarmerie qui arrivent sur les lieux
le seul témoin c'est un petit garçon de
café qui était en train d'installer sa
terrasse toi le matin il divo dit qu'est
ce que j'ai vu il dit j'ai eu un gros
camion noir à un éléphant est descendu à
péter vitrine ou déchets gardien puis il
ya les pêcheurs moteur qui amuseront et
des bons c'est sa voix l'immatriculation
dégâts mais on le dit ni c'est une belle
victoire
c'était tellement spectaculaire j'ai
presque pensé une seconde à noter numéro
du yoga mûrement vingt dix quand même la
marque du camion aurait dit j'en sais
rien c'était un gros camion noir
j'ai toujours été de me casser qu'on
commence à se met en colère
dimon avait dit quand même l'éléphant
c'est un éléphant d'asie
j'habite à sarcelles moitié sud
que j'y connais vous savez très bien
l'éléphant d'afrique il a des grandes
oreilles éléphants d'asie
il a des petits serait là le garçon et
diva là je peux pas vous dire
il avait une cagoule
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est le combat il s'énerve jamais non
pas derrière jean-marie obtient alors
celle inverse alors
[Applaudissements]
saleh ne rien à voir je vais pas dire un
gros d'un gros coup de la soirée c'est
s'éloigner
c'est historique c'est historique oui tu
sais comment michel et la boujenah il a
raconté une blague sur un perroquet
histoire c'est un peu rauque est élevé
dans un bordel exactement et il
l'insulté il a su tout le monde il est
complètement grossier et la meuf qui a
eu ce perroquet évidemment il est un peu
plus elle s'en débarrasserait le vent
sur le bon coin
oui donc à le vent sur le bon coin elle
prévient la nouvelle la nouvelle de
personne qui va acheter le père aucun
visa attention attention s'il a été
élevé dans un bordel et il dit des
choses très très très vilaine plus que
jean marie billa et du coup elle dit non
mais c'est pas là moi j'ai tellement
envie d'avoir un perroquet donc elle le
récupère elle pose le perroquet aux
mille son salon et qui lie à sa voisine
carey avec ses deux filles et le
perroquet nouveau bordel nouvelle [ __ ]
aurait dit non non je suis désolé on
avait prévenu mais ça serait du que vous
allez voir nous inquiétez pas le
perroquet il va être vraiment vraiment
de dresser n'y aura pas de souci
et là il ya son mari qui rentre au fond
de ce nouveau bond des nouvelles plus
mais toujours secondaire
et ça passe très bien les choses
une femme qui appelle son fils ça lui a
laissé l'appartement pendant les parties
en vacances alors la paix lors ça va tu
toi tu t'en sors sans nous à la maison
et tout va bien là le chat il va bien
ben non le chat il est mort non mais ça
va pas tu as aucune éducation mais
comment tu m'annonça le chat est mort je
dis ça comme ça ym être des formes tu
pourrais dire tel le charger pas à moi y
jouer avec sa baballe sur le balcon et
puis la balle a roulé les tombes et il a
voulu la suivre il est tombé avec est
vraiment un bon il m'a mis et va bien
même amis et jouer avec ça va bien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
donc j'en ai encore une petite un peu
dégueu remarquer qu'un prof qui couche
avec son élève c'est un pédophile alors
qu'une preuve tu couches avec son élève
c'est une première donne
[Applaudissements]
moi j'attends mon cas mais ça se passe
dans une classe et un professeur qui des
années la vie gay bouder des oui il dit
c'est quoi ta ville préférée durant moi
monsieur j'aime bien washington des
bombes à l'écrire au tableau déjà je
rigole j'aime bien paris de marif alors
c'est le mec qui tombe amoureux d'une
russie pendant la guerre après la guerre
ouais et
très amoureux elle emmène en russie chez
elle et 45 ans [ __ ] c'est son
anniversaire il ya 82 ans et lui dit
hier pour ton anniversaire
voilà ton cadeau lui tend une enveloppe
il ouvre c'est un billet aller retour
paris à lui dit mon amour mon amour
qu'est ce quelle jolie attention revoir
paris tu sais pas ce que ça représente
pour moi saute dans le dans le train il
arrive à paris dans son quartier dans
beaucoup de choses qui ont changé 1 mais
il reconnaît son porche
quand même qui lui est en pierre toile
est toujours là et en face il ya une
cordonnerie
c'était sa cordonnerie à lui tu vois
donc c'est la même bas mais elle est
tout déchirer et tu as tout dégoulinante
les to et fouille dans son bourg de
veille et un ticket tu vois de ses
chaussures qui l'avait mis dans cette
cordonnier louve la botte ping an c'est
la même clochette
il ya 45 ans 30 il voit personne aurait
dit il ya quelqu'un là voient d'un très
vieux monsieur dans la réserve qui dit
oui qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour
vous mais guerrière son ticket et 10 of
pas grand chose me va je tente quand
même le coup je vous avais laissé une
paire de chaussures chez vous ah oui
c'était quoi comme chauffeur fournis
cette aide et les mocassins
ah oui et mocassins c'était pas des
mocassins marrons du dc c'était des
mocassins marrons et very well il y
avait le pompon sur les chaussures
gauche qui étaient abîmées diois quoi
dieu lui dit alors elles sont prêts à
[Applaudissements]
depuis que la grève est finie donc dans
le métro ça face à paris dans le métro
tout le monde sait qu'à parler dans le
métro surtout le matin les gens le font
la gueule ils tiennent le journal et
puis il ya un mec tout petit que
personne ne voit qu'elle a un côté là
une superbe jeune fille que qui tient
entre elles le voient même pas lui élevé
à la dans le métro personnes parlent à
personne avant elle le regarde tout le
monde le regarde le xix siècle être
contestées
ça va parce que jonas genévrier besoin
et tout et puis ça côté m côté arrivées
le mec iv c'est bio c'est quoi je suis
d'une autre planète
je suis fan de terre jusqu'au bout et il
se peut vers je suis pas d'ici
tous les ans une vision non mais
attendez on commence à dire c'est
impossible d'appeler un contrôleur la
mecque tard elle passa et tous les amis
et y alors au bout d'un moment elle
avait débuté dans le planet et d'où je
suis même de très loin
si le planet a même pas de nom et je
suis super du bien alors au bout d'un
mois et lui mais comment vous vivez là
bas sais pas comment vous y a pas de
riez pas de femmes on vit différemment
avant mais route à vous n'avez pas
d'amis ou vous tiens par exemple ça vous
arrive de baisers oui mais comment vous
faites mais tu peux pas faire ça ce soir
tu peux pas rêver nous quelque chose de
propre
alors ces deux combats qu'ils se
rencontrent ils savent à toi dis ça va
merveilleusement bien
je suis allée enfin je réalise un rêve
mais soft un saint-bernard et depuis que
j'ai ce chien chez moi je suis le plus
heureux des hommes
je me réveille avec lui je petit-déj'
avec lui je vais te courir avec lui le
soir je regarde la télé avec lui le
week-end on se balade en ensemble et si
le bonheur est dit oui mais quand même
c'est un chien énorme lady son ami
imagine si un jour tu as une femme vif
et une femme rendre l'appartement
[Rires]
voilà
jean rdpc du rhin
c'est le nouveau bâti alors ces deux
vieux que ça sur un bon public
ils sont un petit peu alzheimer et il ya
un commerçant ambulant au loin tu te
seras et le tigre sauvage et dit tiens
moi j'ai bien une glace fatwa à l'oti
dit oui bonne idée une glacerie bombe a
dit je vais y aller tu veux quoi toi et
du coup tu moi j'ai bonne chocolat
pistache et 10 et toi moi je prends
vanille fraise neutre le quand même
c'est que d'un peu perdu la boule c'est
mieux que du neuf et dix savent à chacun
la pistache vanille fraise aux deux
heures après il revient avec deux dogues
ce qui a laissé sur le banc et 10 et la
moutarde
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
routhier donc une jeune serveuse qui
vient d'être embauché l'a pas encore
tout compris mais bon on est en train de
recopier le menu sur une ardoise et puis
elle finit de recopier les crient dessus
sandwich au thon 6 euros et plats du
jour là branle à 2 du chef 11 euros et
la repasse derrière le comptoir il ya un
routier qui dit pardon la demoiselle
oui c'est vous qui faites à la brandade
du chef oui pourquoi
oui vous laver les mains voilà c'est
l'examen de fin d'année donc cas le
docteur qui ramène trois fous qui
demande aux premiers fous il dit
trois fois quatre offres mercredi il
appelle le deuxième il y trois fois 4485
non mais c'est pas possible il apprend
le troisième 3 x 4 direct du 10 12 10
mais comment tu as fait dit j'ai divisé
mercredi par 1400 kg
[Applaudissements]
romario basis élevé qui est bourrée
havre morin salle avec booba et quake 4
heures du matin et en péniblement chez
lui et voit chez les voisins il ya des
citrouilles des belles grosses
citrouilles comme ça ni caire près ce
qu'on les a stick est vrai qu'elle se
mêle comme ça et là je fasse ce qu'il
veut et prend il n'a rien trouvé de la
soirée bien il sent bien qui va dormir
sur la béquille et le veulent qu'ils
escaladent la petite clôture
il se met à genoux devant la grosse
citrouille écart et la frappe comme ça
fait un bout il sort son opinel et il
commence à faire un trou serré dans la
citrouille
c'est un trou présent de ce mythe non ça
rentre pas aux autres il a grandi le
trou est un moment à soldats et la
dinguerie une bagnole de flics arrivent
avec bas le phare en pleine gueule le
flic qui dit qu'à l'heure du liban ouais
bien que shaw train de baiser
mais me choque c'est une citrouille
l'audi à merde on a déjà passé minuit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il faut désamorcer plus c'est pour ça tu
veux jouer ont désamorcé toi ces deux
chasseurs bourré librement et sans là il
ya un qui regarde il voit un deltaplane
fait [ __ ] le canard c'est le plus gros
que j'ai vu de ma vie
il épaule paris tire pas de se rater
fois oui n'empêche qu'il a lâché sa
proie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]